oh you like the beats Arad Simba if you
want to it beats only like 45 seconds
he's giving me a longer beat in case I
want to freestyle because I will drop a
freestyle yes is it Jonathan Jonathan
Abram you could say he's kind of
understated but everybody knows he's
always a celebrated yeah come and leave
it dated yeah go and just debate it if
you really want it [ __ ] hate it
hey hey listen the guy is Jonathan Abram
he is a safety for Mississippi State he
is in the NFL Draft he is a
self-proclaimed number one safety second
team all-american 2018 terms of a bunch
of publications third team all-american
first team all-sec SEC Defensive Player
of the Week a bunch of times a hard
hitter a missile and you know what I'm a
by the end of this podcast deem him the
left go show NFL draft player what I
mean by that is you were the first draft
player that I've interviewed I am NOT
deep into the draft yet I'm still
thinking about the NFL levy on an Odell
that if this goes well I may just make
you the the podcast player does that
excite you because I love safeties bro
I love safeties I love hard-hitting
safeties I love missiles I think that in
the box safeties are getting a bad rap
right now but when you run a four four
or five I don't care if it's in the box
or outside the box say hello to
everybody how's it going today
how you feel talking about the end of
box safe do you just look with landing
just go stacks
staff for the in the box safety yeah but
what's funny is I see that the in the
Box safety knows how to tackle
oh yeah lock safety knows how to hit the
end the Box safety might become a
linebacker like Mark Barron and then he
could do anything you want what do you
think about when you hear that phrase
right now here at all
time I mean he's really managed from
reporters and draft analysts like
sitting out and talking with teams it's
never your in the box safety it's always
just you know closer to the line of
scrimmage you want we want you to put
like nickel cover the slot guys right no
accent about the post things like that
so they never say you know stuff like in
the box eight you see the stronger free
and you know what I think I'm seeing the
word nickel a lot with you yeah because
it's versatility yeah you can play in
the backend you can play at the line you
can grab that guy in the slot I even
played a dime linebacker did you yeah
how does how does one start picking up
more do the coaches just throw you into
those positions where do you study it
you have to you know see for me that's
the one thing coaches always knew that I
knew the system thoroughly like I knew
it from starting from fronts and the
linemen saying what a three takes
supposed to be the linebacker face you
know coverages I knew the whole nine so
is there pressure in this part of the
year to say I'm the best safety like I
feel like are you as you have you heard
anybody else say that yet yes
who else has said it I haven't seen it
but you're Brooke saves me a number one
make I am your number one make sure guys
I think our Matt Miller has you and yet
Miller yeah but then have you heard any
other safeties say there are actually
the best
no no that's interested they don't
believe they know it's not true mmm so I
mean they know I'm going Aaron lie
what's it like not to have to lie feels
good I was I've watched a few interviews
of you I've seen a few things and I I
think it's always interesting because
you're now you're 21 22 okay I'm 32 so I
grew up ten years man lots gonna change
look at me this is your future you're in
trouble
I saw you said like you watch Ronnie a
lot yeah Ronnie a lot is the safety that
even my generation watched but we didn't
really watch it either it was really
generation before me but that's how much
of a baller Ronnie Lott was good a lot
of guys like that John Lynch like those
guys were Fowler's yes he used to go in
there and just he's a doll he's just
across people yeah like I never seen
tackles like that before
what the hell who would show you that
like who would put that in front of you
I mean just me and my cousin we just his
name is Lawrence we should just watch a
lot of football and still to this day if
you go in his house yeah in Columbia
Mississippi he has on his wall like oh
just like google pictures oh just prints
out Google pictures this is from we were
like 10 like Nate are just all on his
wall and in every position one position
safety only safety only safety so did he
play safety also uh he played kind of
like corner but it was good that's is
who we watched and you guys would just
sit there and just watch sanity's who
are the other names John birthday oh
yeah Bob Sanders I favor Bob Sanders and
you immediately went people forget about
Bob Sanders they do this because he was
like five eight he wanted decent wages
it just didn't last that long but even
out of Iowa he was amazing and then
those first few years in Indy it was
Payton and Bob Sanders yeah it was the
man what about Brian Dawkins Brian
Dawkins as my grade is my favorite
player of all time my favorite has to be
of all the time enemy Erie just simply
for the fact you know nobody don't what
he done 25 picks 25 SEC's 25 for fathers
mmm like that he's the national champion
in college oh yeah NFL Hall of Famer NFL
Super Bowl champion no one but the net
stat line no one in the field can say
they have day except for him he's the
first he's the first and the only person
Wow are you sure he's the first 25 25 -
I do I get the feeling that you don't
want him to be the only I don't know why
I don't I don't I don't if I'm chasing
once that that's the only stat I'm Jason
versatility yes and we say wins so the
topic no I mean me personally I saw them
you know people say Pro bows and things
like that for me it's all about
championship hmm I only want one
championship in my lifetime I was like
nine years oh really
peewee peewee the Golden Eagles what was
your team Trustmark Bank Trustmark Bank
and now coming out for the championship
game Jonathan Abram leads Trustmark Bank
you guys won and it was probably amazing
yeah you got orange slices and Pizza Hut
we ran
one play and we school it almost every
time what was the play get the ball to
John get about it
quarterback booty every time and in it
never failed what so which what do you
think the percentage of players the NFL
are that played quarterback when they
were younger I mean not in times I do
think yeah basically I played
quarterback so right it's high like I
would say at college most of your
teammates probably played quarterback in
high school yeah and they probably
couldn't even throw that's true they ran
around but I actually have the state
regular it doesn't house in Mississippi
62 and when you are we talking is that
like total passing and rushing yeah pass
16 to any in Tennessee no Mississippi
Mississippi that's a pretty good state
to do it in man yeah who are the other
best athletes with you growing up in my
hometown yeah like in Mississippi like
in your town like where you're from we
had a lot of guys a lot of the guys
played baseball top corner Forbes
Anthony offer
DeMarcus Evans Tomas Connelly just a
bunch of us we all play traveling ball
yeah all those guys did you play
baseball too I was way bird at baseball
you realize that that's like a popular
thing right here my dad's got paid forty
four hundred thirty million dollars yeah
my team played for paid for price arm
I'm all about but I'm just thinking also
Pat mahomes former baseball player Kyler
Murray
he was like it's people are now us like
you have better field vision if you play
baseball
you're a better athlete I know I know a
lot of people that say that baseball
players might be the best athletes cuz
yeah because you don't realize how hard
it is to play shortstop or third base
like in to kiss that small ball coming
120 miles at you
wow it's kind of like catching a running
back in the hole yeah and then you know
a lot of guys playing field so we play
we like the 8 mm soda close like 10
inches so it's pretty much a hand you
pretty much just catching the ball with
your hands it's got a little pain
knowing what was what's your hometown
like a small place I mean it's not
really much to do like 6,000 people
total population right I mean only thing
they do is just watch sports it's just a
sports town I lived in Nebraska and it
was I was my first job population 25,000
and all they did was watch the Oscars
like what did they watch where you grow
like what was the team southern me
Southern Miss
like 15 min Joy's oh did you ever think
about going there I did but only thing I
was just going to get back to the sec
cuz you went to Georgia he's a coach
left you had a great first year coach
left and you said I can't do it yeah why
did you feel the need to transfer I mean
I was just so comfortable with coach
Brewer you know he was really like a
father figure to me and so just I just
didn't feel comfortable standing there
with that home because that was like my
entire reason for going to Georgia mmm
to play for him so then you opened it up
and did every team just come call yeah I
have 42 scholarships on its own signing
day on site on site you stack like dad
do they just come in the mail yeah they
just melons in school and then would you
like neatly stack them or not like cuz
so when we got in so we had a sign I did
like one o'clock so we had 17 guys
signed d12 like piyo 5 schools that year
yeah and like we just come in it was
already stacked up you know the people
who had already committed they had they
want paper down but like I didn't know
where I was going so they hate all my
papers right there Wow
and it was between Mississippi State and
who else Alabama LSU why did you go to
Mississippi State
I don't know I kind of go right away I
can't and I just kind of rule it list
you out you know like the day before and
talked to coach Pruitt on signing day
and he was just like you know don't come
here for me oh he was at Mississippi
State I was at Alabama oh damn I'm an
idiot
yeah he was like don't come here for me
go somewhere where you gonna be happy
like literally everybody at Mississippi
State thought I was going out about if I
were you told me that the the father
figure was at Alabama like yeah he's
going to Alabama and just talking to
some of the guys from Bama it was like
we really thought you were coming here
like we was surprised like that you
didn't come and so just when he talked
to me and told me that so I don't know I
always wanted to be that person to you
know beat the team on top mm-hmm
so that's kind of why I went to the jury
college I went to I didn't wanna go to
East Mississippi you know the last
chance you yeah so we end up beating you
go I Stan the Hornets on yes that was
the last chance to you naturally that's
easy too first episode we beat them oh
the where they were supposed to come out
and be great yeah you were the reason
that that covers on the sideline going
going my place work these
stink like that because of you guys yes
I hate I had tacos I had a fourth phone
booth three pvu and I got eating that
Wildcat quarterback in school and I
blocked the field goes you hit that kid
that was supposed to be like the next
like he was the transfer from Florida
State or whatever oh did you tell my
season three oh I'm gonna tell you you
talk about Kingdom season okay
I'm Tom bad the one Mississippi two
Mississippi okay so what I'm saying is
the one that's amazing you did that
coach from season three I hate with all
my heart you don't know how many people
do I need I need like if I was a child
on that team if I was one of those
players I would sue him for derailing my
career completely like he's on camera
calling a bunch of kids like [ __ ]
and talking about no one's gonna get
signed guess I'm taking you to court bro
like that's crazy but you were on season
two now I'm gonna go watch it and you
just watch the first episode number five
you can't call you you can't you kidnap
me so if you have an IMDB page are you
an actor now no kinda you're on Netflix
yeah that's a great one I was on Netflix
for one second I need a huge wife yeah
about what just about my life well what
would the be okay I'll be your producer
alright so what's a typical day what are
we gonna show the people that's so
entertaining about depends on what
season weekend so right now we're trying
to mow so get up every day by season oh
dude your life's a movie right now
yeah well you're whipping around the
country you're doing interviews you're
meeting with teams they're all going you
know John I could see you as a future
safety here in New York and then then
you move on then you're in a gym and
you're training and you're moving weight
and you're like this is [ __ ] crazy my
dreams come together then you're gonna
get drafted this part is so dope bro
it's a whirlwind you're never gonna have
this experience that's true I mean
that's one movie I'm enjoying but like
in all season though like because I'm
fun not just cuz I like I got a bunch of
hobbies like I like shooting pool holy
hunt fishing ATVs you name it like to
him cutter you the West at like what if
you were to challenge me in one of those
things all of them I could get out of
them
bowling that was completely unnecessary
yeah I'm just saying bowling like you
didn't have to go follow the number get
you soon pull them okay what are you
typically baller like 150 160 I can
maybe get you once I feel I can get
around there all right so yeah I think
so but then see you're gonna see if you
let me get in the groove Oh about five
six strikes all right beer pong gonna
take you down all right you got me
bowling pool how are you poor I'm pretty
good it just blows me because I have I
take some bone here sighs I try to try
shots that you're gonna be like why are
you trying it you what if I make it you
gonna be like oh my gosh
it didn't dress to say which is gonna be
easy bank shots now atvs I'd have to be
that corny dude that rides on the back
and holds on to you and I don't wanna I
could do it no we put you away okay cuz
I own the dirt bike
I don't two wheels yeah I can't you
asked why I had to get my mom kind of
balance I get on a dirt bike and put it
on one wheel they're gonna tell you to
stop dude that's why I don't have anyone
anymore
yeah yeah oh man so in Philadelphia
that's all they do
bike like there's just wheelies all da
day I love you I watch it all the time
amazed i watched she got scared for
those kids she know he be throwing hand
off the side besides tonight it's great
do everything the other safety is though
you mentioned you keep mentioning
Antoine Bethea yeah how this is not a
very well known safety but I'm curious
why he's so big for you I don't know I
just I feel like he was overlooked you
know he was him and Bob together were
like the perfect duo you know they
compliment each other so well and then
he's just stuck around so I mean he's
done a lot of things right if you just
he just resigned recently two years to
the Cardinals right so like lasted
forever that so that says a lot about
that mean he takes care of his buddy
take care of his body he's he knows the
game like like know what I mean because
that simple fact that you're that oh and
you're still playing yeah I mean some
value to the team I saw in your ID story
last night it was a picture of Times
Square and you wrote
stay down your life can change in one
year one year where were you a year for
me last year I was at Mississippi State
and I was cut to plan on coming out I
was to the point where I was just kind
of rushing it you know like most kids do
because I kind of feel like that's they
do now they just put that stupid
it's gotta be three years right because
if you come out after four you weren't
good enough to come out after three but
that's not true though yeah and so for
me I was just contemplating and you know
just talking to the people in my life
there was just like you gonna you got a
chance to go you're not gonna get
drafted before the third round so there
was just like third and after and so I
would say the point I was just like man
I don't care long as I just make a team
mm-hmm you're just ready to play in the
NFL yeah like I stopped being ready for
the in the field like cuz I was just
tired of college yeah but just going
back getting my finishing up my degree
graduate you know that made my mom proud
me made my entire family proud and so
just there and then now just looking at
what I made a year from now I went back
had another great year put on some more
some more great feeling the other and
now I'm like I said no more safety in
the country yeah got the chance to go
first day you know and so like now I'm
sitting here with you I wouldn't have
been here last year you don't know
because you had guys like yeah minko
Darwin then the one who snuck in there
was the kid from Virginia Tech yes the
brother of Edmunds mmm Terrell Edmonds
he snuck in there than you had Justin
Reed from Stanford yeah yeah running
Harrison from Bama correct what did you
have last year you had the kid from
Texas
Elliott Elliott so you've really been
like keeping an eye on the safety yeah
you had the guy who what did you think
of the Saturday's last year the year
before or that one the one you're just
talking about I think I like a lot of
those guys oh my the one I mainly like
his Darwin just because the way he plays
he kind of reminds me myself he plays
like balls to the wall every single play
and he can do anything he could do it
all and he's mad he's I'm phreak phreak
he's tall long can jump can hit hard and
he's a baller dude he just likes to play
Darwin if you watching this you ugly
damn yes my god so that's what I
realized also reading stuff about you is
you're not afraid to call people out no
I believe here when you were playing
your former Georgia team you said you
were gonna beat the breaks off of that
was the plane what happened what
happened man we just went in there and
like I was telling a lot of those guys
like they had never played that George
and I'm just like man listen it's gonna
be loud as [ __ ]
it's gonna be loud like when the offense
on the field you the dollars gonna be
defense with the picket fence in the
deal I was like it's gonna be crazy so
we get out there the first Drive and
like coach mother said like we got he
got outcoached and we got our play we
try to throw a swing route and they peel
the renzo Carter oh my gosh and after
day it was just like I entire game plan
just like let's just put together some
some BS and just you can all try one hit
yeah just try to get out of here because
there's there sometimes one play changes
the whole game
Danya on the first in the first place Oh
first my defense Oh exit to get back it
wasn't the first play against office
beef is when I deferred I ran a
flea-flicker the first play did you
fight I was down in the box
I was the boxing I was covering Teddy
flea-flicker corner came off his man
chill episteme a 70-yard bum birds
playing a game and so you've been
talking about we're gonna beat the
breaks off and you're sitting there
going Dan they got my day I'm like cuz
you don't if I heard that an All SEC
safety say they're gonna beat the breaks
first play I'm calling a flea-flicker
yeah if you're gonna be that excited to
beat the breaks off then you're gonna
have to hit the brakes because this is
going off yeah that was good love PR if
you say a quote during the week they're
probably gonna attack you that yes play
so after that cuz mother was just like
no we gotta go home no he was just like
after day he was just like when he came
to media for me he was like do not like
even have the guy said that would be
like don't say nothin crazy man but you
were that's what you felt
yeah yes I really felt where are you in
terms of using trash talkers entering
the NFL wow I'm talking on the field I
want to know I want to know what was one
that it even made you laugh it was so
good coming out damn so do you get how
do you get I had one I said something to
a guy again you'll have to say the name
of the guy not system to a guy from LA
Tech last year and he turned around like
it was so bad he was like damn bro why
you got to say there
his feelings like cuz they hurt and I
thought about I was like damn I said
that was too much that was wrong
like cuz I'll just go for on the field
like ah I'll be doing research
I got research everything so I'll be
knowing about your family
wow I know it all I'm gonna take sighs
I'm taking shot receiver hey receiver
your mom got a thick neck I'll be like
man hey I hate that your son look like
you y'all both looking damn damn and it
any have you seen it impact people -
it's like they get angry changes their
whole game that's what I like cuz then
they try to get over again especially
receive if they get over-aggressive be
trying to come in you're not doing have
you ever been gotten so good that you
had to look at the person go down like
I'm always waiting for like a guard to
like stand up and be like if you come
into Tori over the ticker it off oh yes
yes freshman year stop talking we played
them so don't say it's drizzling so I go
out there with a hoodie on and I see
deer hearing I'm only 18 at the time
this man is warming up in a crop top his
arms are the size of my thighs I'm like
I'm like I ain't saying that nobody I'm
just like he isn't off the bus Khyber so
I'm talking so we ran something called
shark bliss which is away from the Titan
II into the open side man first time I
ran I end up getting TfL um he play for
the Dolphins now Kendra Kendra he tried
to were very feeling I'm getting teal
feel I'm height that's your first play
of your freshman year no no this is
doing a Bama game okay so I get the TLC
I'm height so we come back so as I'm
creeping know we ran - we ran in the
Blitz later on in the game I'm creeping
up I'm talking [ __ ] I'm just I'm coming
man they ran a counter I see Derek here
in stand up like this and then come back
and a card
no not no go Darry hurry and so I take
him on and I tried to hit him high blue
so I fell on my face got a mud pie he's
bouncing around the ears for another
forty and so coach got me out the game
cuz we went go line up today and so he
just paid me on here he said John you
know he country could say Joe I give you
credit song most people wouldn't try it
you got some hard well I was sowing bear
take the Mud Pie on trail I was so
embarrassed how many times did they
watch the film of that I went Sunday we
watched it over and over he playing he
thought it was so funny but I got good I
got got good again and again I blissed
off this cam Robinson the man did not
even look at me he hit me with a
backhand like to the back of the hill me
sleeve me by 10 yards down the field
okay like BAM he's a monster two years
they had a bunch of monster so did you
not talk [ __ ] for a little bit after
that no okay I was embarrassed I'm
saying like even the next game you're
like I'm good
showers to the point now they don't
matter if you get me now just be like
man that was a fluke yeah
Derrick Henry man his legs are so long
like the first time I saw him I was like
why is your waist so high it's crazy
like it's it's like legs and then like
he'd be like white with gaoqi that's
great other guys in your team we got
some freaks okay the two that I hear out
the most Jeffrey Simmons and Montez
sweat I don't know why but they always
forget about we got the number one well
I don't know the draft too much so
please that the number one center I just
did a podcast say his name jinke Alton
Jenkins I was just on a podcast where
they said they said Adam who's the one
player in the draft that you think can't
mess I was like I'm just gonna go with
Quinn and Williams
you're just saying can't-miss like he's
Fletcher Cox like I'll take it that was
great
but I haven't met you yet the horrible
comparison
Wow welcome thanks up here family
Mississippi State Fletcher you gonna
compare it you gonna say flesh your [ __ ]
no it can't doesn't have to be just a
team I don't know how big is Jeffery six
four three hundred all muscle look
thanks Peck all right so I went and
watched a bunch of clips of Jeffrey
Simmons last night and I was like all
right this guy is something special see
he is he is like a Chris Jones he is
kind of like a Fletcher Cox he's one of
those I just think that Quinn and
Williams kind of has the body type I
think Jeffrey Simmons is more athletic
than Fletcher Cox like yesterday back in
Quinn Williams you know everybody's
different guys but they're different
tell people Jeff would've had to combine
he'd have been healthy Oh yourself what
around a four seven right no no totally
no Jeffrey Simmons to me as a clowny and
I look at Quinn and Williams as a
Fletcher they're different guy like
cloudy he's gonna like hit the set the
edge and then he's also gonna rush the
passer while Fletcher Cox is like I'm
just gonna bash through your face but
that's awkward oh yeah but I think he's
more versatile he is he is I think he's
moved and then so but not a lot of
people know tore his ACL yeah but I know
a lot of people that still haven't gone
in the first round that's how good he is
yeah that's a testament to him a special
kid yes he really is and then like just
in some of my interviews you know they
ask me about him you know and I had a
couple of team that can do I think he's
going to first not tell them yes simply
because I think a team who gonna trap
Jeff is gonna be somebody who know
they're gonna be in the playoffs
and they know he's gonna be coming back
full force around playoff time if he is
there that's the thing is for a guy like
Jeff middle the round end of the round
let's say you go to the same place
middle the round end of the round
dude that's the best place to go yeah
cuz you're going to a team that probably
has a really good culture there's a lot
of those teams and voids yeah yes
and that or teams that are looking for
that one piece that's exciting but then
again at the same point you go the first
pick of the second round so related
columns what yeah you know what I mean
you get at your contract one year sooner
sorry I'm talking the real [ __ ] about
the you know if you're out yeah then you
get to go ever you want
yeah and you get to cash in also dragged
in an extension I
get somewhere and be stuck there you
were to ball out so hard they gotta keep
this guy it'd be like you see we got
every side yeah that's that's definitely
it
but Simmons you definitely see as a
first round pick special kid we're
talking Fletcher Cox a deviant clown he
is all special Montez he had that
combine performance top five like
without a doubt in my opinion he should
be number one if we taking a defensive
guy he should be number one really even
over Bosa it's not even close it's not
even close like some I'm telling you I
don't know what Mel Kiper
is it's gonna be broke down - he's so
fluent he's sold so this oh that his
brother said he's gonna be his brother
said that's his brother he's supposed to
say hey that's what he's supposed to say
I'm not gonna say my brother not gonna
be greater than me when I'm they got me
yeah I'm the one pick yeah I'm gonna
boast my brother that's what he's
supposed to do right then they is
basically going off of Oh his uncle play
his granddad play yeah so he got the
name yeah I got the name but he's short
sweaty six six mmm he's not fast sweat
around a four-for-one fastest indie lion
history yeah sweet got it all and sweat
strong I think my thing with guy with
defenses like yours you guys complement
each other so well
yeah Simmons and him fit together so
well you on the back end is so well and
then I'm going man I don't know if
Simmons opening and stuff up for for
sweat no this sweat open up stuff for
Simmons no just individual just go kiss
don't think I tell people if you take
Jeffery or sweat and put him at Bama we
talking about y'all gonna be sitting
number one picking a dress just because
it's Bama
when you got guys like BAM OH Quinton
Williams don't you can't forget this
Quinton Williams break1 Davis eyes their
books right Anthony gins Wilkins let me
know what's the other one name 47 I
forgot his name yes I know Clemson no
from bamboo yeah so you got to think
about that front five who can you do
more of these [ __ ] guys
okay eww okay who can you double if you
double one person right you put in
everything Jennings one-on-one with a
back he's 66 to 280 Christian Miller
Christian Miller so you put him
one-on-one with the running back
just punish that kid yeah it's not fair
so versus Jill I didn't seem Jeff get
double-teamed triple teen doubled and
chipped and then they sliding the
protectionist switch and he's still
winning
got 15 sex in a year twenty five and two
years you're gonna need to get three
percent of Jeffrey Simmons correct
because this is phenomenal no this is
this is doing a great job this is from
watching film yeah like the ones who I
think are really good like in this deal
on class or the guys from Clemson I hate
those guys are the real deal really
yes yes not a complement each other
really well it's unbelievable yes
those guys are they some freak there's
some four horsemen type of I don't watch
i watch the championship game sometimes
it'd be only one of them boys and there
they put the rotates in the back of
thing cuz they can and they still ow
okay so who are the other players let's
just do this who what quarterback do you
like the most in the draft
Justin Hugh was that your quarterback no
what was he with to tie Bergen oh no
he's Justin Herbert yeah however Hubert
Herbert he is phenomenal
really I've actually heard a lot of
teams that they're thinking about not
drafting this year because they want him
next year
I really wish he would it came out this
year like just watching the film like
he's really good okay who's your
favorite running back John Jacobs he ran
a four six yesterday it don't matter
slow no if he breaks away you're not
gonna kitchen that's all that matters
the thing is he has great acceleration
he's one of those guys when I played
like even playing against him you can
tell like he don't care like you talk
[ __ ] he don't care he's happy to be out
on the field at all times like he won't
contact like you have guys who they say
he finishes through contact he
initiating the contact ripping through
the contact craving the conclave in the
cut that he'll what about Y receiver
mmm-hmm there's a lot of there's a lot
of interesting types this year most
interesting being DK I know I got you
not because he sold me if I had to go to
if I'm going to receivers I'm gonna
break it down into out wide and sly sure
the one day really impressed me the most
and I know these gone
I'm sorry Mississippi stay put AJ Brown
he really had really under Ole Miss wide
receiver yeah I really did come by and
then just watching him catch the ball
like he got some really strong hands
like I was watching he was just one hand
he like left and right he was falling
one time on the sidelines just one
handing that thing I was like wow what
about the tight ends cuz there's a few
the to Iowa ones not both of those guys
do you like both of them I like Hakkasan
better thank you
alright see is the more complete tidy
this is what's happening right now we I
like to make things things you are you
I'm gonna create the Jonathan Abram
draft team all the guys you're saying
right now are the people that I am
putting my full weight behind and say
that they're gonna be great all right
Herbert go from quarterback
I'm however from last year because he's
not next year column or column ur is the
guy
yes running back just Jacob wide
receiver AJ Brown tight end Hawkins I
give you another receive gotta have to
receive okay my second we're gonna break
this down my second receiver is gonna be
well you got hey I gotta have two in the
slot Jaylon Smith iy from Louisville
really yes because I mean I watch the
film the guys always open he just he
just yeah it's the offense sometimes I
mean if he came by last shot that he
would have he'd been in a better
position okay oh and then a slot I got
to put debo semi and slide damage here I
like your team a lot hey we gonna get
all and then Hawkinson I like both of
them but I think when I watch them I go
we've seen no offense like there are a
lot of really good receiving tight ends
but if I can get a baby Grunk I'm
awesome if I can get a Vance McDonald if
I can get because I feel like H is more
like Fant their receivers and they're
great but if I can get a guy that that
is so versatile Iike Kittel that can
block or didn't get out and then run
someone over
that's Hawkinson how you make ladies
after the catch you know I agree that's
the one out too I know you're gonna go
Simmons and you're gonna go Montez for
your interior D lineman and your edge
yeah but my other is I'm gonna get you
were saying here
Gary a lot of questions about him dude
lobby for any with him he is a freak but
everyone says well then why didn't he
produce on the field I mean man because
he was he was battling some Nate some
some nagging injuries yeah and so I mean
but that's just how it is but he's just
one of those twos in the gym or you look
over and you're like damn Oh ain't gotta
look over he coming right there he's
standing over me really push to see
who's the crew who do you workout with
right now it was me now I've transferred
to college of those guys cause I went
today pro days and stuff so now I'm back
with interfere guys so me Jamal Adams
Dante Jackson who else we got in there
Xavier woods yeah Corey Corey Moore and
then where are you guys tradable area of
the country in Dallas am JP dam so
that's pretty awesome enough Jamal there
man yeah we had truing it out of the day
yeah true but it's so funny he go by the
name but Jamal though yeah I mean this
is all prosafety in year one yeah I mean
what kind of blue beard team you learn
from that you're - yeah but I mean you
could've got him near one here either
good yeah I mean just sitting back just
talking to him I mean you know he
charter he tried to help me out as much
as he can you know just trying to show
me the ropes every time I look on his IG
story is being like she trashed out by
that guy yeah it looks like Igor Igor no
listen either change of life
let me explain to people what I'm
talking about I go on Jamal Adams story
they work out I didn't realize you were
in the same gym so it's definitely gonna
see one part exactly but I didn't know
you're there but anyway I see this guy
that is stretching out Jamal and I
messaged him all the time like dude this
looks like it hurts
it's like bending his leg away back
going to the side he's putting pressure
ripping his foot and I'm like he's gonna
break your ankle and now so you guys
call him Igor what's his real name
Igor no damn you guys got a
super-stretch guy named Igor from Brazil
you stretch the [ __ ] out he stays like
200 like pro guys and when you first saw
him doing it were you nervous not like
because I'm not watching like gemologist
like
I forgot marquees maybe not there with
us to him so he telling me and Mark is
he like man listen y'all gotta get Igor
cuz it's like 30-minute sessions so I'm
just like bro that [ __ ] like he heard
yes
like he really fold you up into like a
ball and even fold you so I mean I tried
it and I guess probably the best rate
you ever had but do it like after I
workout you can do it just a random day
whenever and so when it's happening what
were you thinking I did not know I can
move like this yes I get there I get
nervous so now he's like I do the NFL
players like fight over them like all
the table just to stretch people yes he
must be exhausted
hey nice wait is he funny he he don't
talk much
wow what a character but I mean he do to
here it takes you have a great day like
inspirational so you have this guy that
barely speaks
he was Igor from Brazil I'll text you
inspirational messages he'll fold you
into a pretzel and then unfold you and
as you unfold you feel like a new person
like that new person sounds like an
angel he like I don't I don't think he's
really exists I think this is a fake
person that you all think is real no but
it's an angel no he's real what do you
expect now the rest of this process but
like what's the year next few weeks like
pro day next week I have a bunch of is a
bunch of is his mind up Ava have one
some tomorrow and Friday I think so is
this just Airport Airport go in there
and there's a lot of times up with my
agent he's done a really good job
shoutout to you Neal Robinson a my
marketing clean race hey yeah so those
guys have a lot and so you know they
gotta schedule now we're so I started me
find everywhere you know cuz I get to
train a lot so they sent teams to me
mmm so people sent like position cause
defensive coordinators to me hey MJ P
and we just meet there do whatever we
need to do right is it typically the
same thing yes pretty much same thing
what do you like about it I'm just
honestly just getting to meet all you
told you so you never know you know
what's gonna happen down the road right
and if you just give the best impression
say what's up has there been here the
fun this is like the storyline
those come out like have you been asked
any weird questions no no no they won't
talk about football yeah I mean because
I feel like the people the eggs weird
questions as the ones would carry the
concerns mmm like yeah like for me is
it's all business like it's just
business like we go in there talk
football acts by my family acts but they
family yeah
that's how it is like free for you like
when did it become like you were saying
that you got done with college football
and the main reason was you're ready to
be a pro you're ready to be around
adults who treat this like it's their
job you you care about your body you
care about your effort all that stuff
you watch film you do all that when did
that start when did you go I'm ready to
be a pro when I turn 18 when I got to
Georgia like right away when I was
reproving like that was the one thing
like just seeing how he went about his
business as a coach and it was just like
because he moved different from other
coaches like and that's why he separated
himself it's kind of part of like you
see what Saban that's why saving is
different people say saving is all about
his business
most people like you don't see saving
smiling and laughing because I mean when
he's you know when you see him most of
times on the football field you don't
see him at home like I've met him off
the field you know he's a really good
guy you know he tried to crack jokes
they don't really be funny but he tried
to crack him yeah but just on the field
like laughs no and he got upset one time
cuz I did because he was like something
about basketball and he was like oh I
kicked your ass in basketball and I
looked at him I was just like cuz I'm
I'm a competitor so I'm just like I
would kick your ass and so he was just
like he thought it was hilarious cuz he
was just like serious yeah and I didn't
know he was like that was a joke and I
was like oh I didn't know you're like no
you challenged me in a sport yeah like
I'm now it's my job to kick your ass yes
yeah so then he said something that
wasn't a joke later on that day cuz I
was at camp coming out junior college
and so he said something in and I
thought it was hilarious he was like
that wasn't a joke to him I was like
well I couldn't tell cuz your face never
changed it was just like when I when I
end up trying to do stand-up comedy I'm
not
you okay cuz you're gonna be like that
joke wasn't funny next joke no the joke
is funny oh yeah I'll be thinking about
it I I have to understand if I can think
about it and it's funny yeah of course
so you've been ready to be a pro since
eighteen you've been getting ready for
it people around you have they always
been like oh no Jonathan's gonna make it
yes have you have you ever had any
haters uh always people gonna hate yeah
of course but I mean I don't surround
myself run it but I just coaches peer
you you know all my coaches don't wanna
[ __ ] with John Hart the one playing on
hard heavy the one thing that I tell
people is no one can say nothing bad
about me because I never leave any
relationship on a bad note like even the
agents I didn't go with if they see me
it's just all love oh yeah because I
mean at the end of the day like I'm like
as I tell you straight up what it is
from the jump
yeah like I don't like it yeah alright
so what's your vibe on me give it to me
yes and I [ __ ] would you leave a room
it's a couple end you consider me an
analyst no I consider myself an [ __ ]
yeah I just say things I like it yeah
but uh some analysts or imbeciles really
especially the ones who own Twitter they
get this blue shake 30,000 followers
they just feel like they are pros that's
me I'm a blue check with my third okay
but this is so so I'm I like some of my
love yeah but it's a few tears just like
if you're so good at your job why aren't
you Scout because scouting sounds like a
really shitty job and this but if people
stop in the street they're like holy
[ __ ] I know you were a scout so like by
the way I'm the one that said Jonathan
Abrams great and nobody knows my name
and nobody knows I exist yes it's
nothing I'm an ego person I like reggae
that's what I'm saying so like it's a
few of them like they write some reports
then you just you just read them yes
like did I've read it all myself and I
was like John here's the thing did he
really watch the field no they denies I
know it's a big thing with this show is
the eye on this guy doesn't lie but most
of people don't pay attention to the eye
they football is I my opinion the
hardest sport
figure out if an individual player is
good I can watch three basketball games
and I could diagnose a guy and that's
what we're trying to do at the NFL
though I'm gonna watch three games of
you against Alabama Georgia three it's
impossible that's how it was but here's
what the problem is these guys have to
watch thousands and so the only time
they have is if I watch three of the
best games that's got to be what I see
no but it's it's a time thing it's not a
bias thing it's not that they don't like
you one they probably don't even know
what they're looking at they don't they
don't and but the problem is is that no
one in football media can admit that
because as soon as you say I don't know
how to watch safety film you're not
allowed to comment on safeties ever
again that's what happens so instead
they go I'm right [ __ ] you I know what
I'm talking about because it's defense
mechanism then the one thing that gets
me like I read something they said he
doesn't have high football IQ well
that's because you're black no no that's
why I wrote it you know locked up yeah
it's [ __ ] up we not go play the race
card no that's not what he done it why
do you think you got an Aloha because
they was imbeciles that's my point and
then you have where do they get that
information from of the reports that's
the thing it's all kind of one-way Hort
yes so doing them but I'm saying I'm
telling you that first report I'm gonna
bet money on it it's not big unless they
were like well he went to Mississippi
State and he's from Mississippi and I'm
from the Northeast and thus my IQ bias
don't know me that too and if that's the
case if you're watching this and you say
that I had low football IQ and you
saying because well I'm from I graduated
salutatorian in my high school I
graduated with 300 honors from
Mississippi State with a business and
marketing degree and I'm already
accepted into grad school for mechanical
engineering talk that [ __ ] John not
intelligent in your stupid talk that
talk that was great see I want to end on
that that was perfect
so I have your official team you like it
let me finish though oh you want to give
me like all the players linebackers okay
Devon white oh yeah absolutely you know
no doubt that's a no no okay corners
Jay baker trade my mother and then who's
your other safety I got to get a nickel
first are you the nickel numbly okay
okay
you see Radley that way we could be
interchangeable we can switch whenever
you get tired and then your other safety
Dustin this is a big one
Thompson give me give me the reason cuz
this is like your blood brother this is
gonna be your bash brother - Safety's
just because he's a great person you
know just sitting out talking to him and
I know one thing about him he's going
steady to film he's gonna put the time
in there's need to be put in like me I'm
gonna actually watch film the other
break you down and if something needs to
be fixed I don't either either part yeah
that I can go to him and do that awesome
I have your official team I know that
now you will be one of the best trash
talkers in the NFL but I'm excited to
see that happen but mainly I'm ready to
do it I'm going to name you the official
favorite player of the left go show for
the NFL Draft
which means if anyone talk [ __ ] about
you I'm coming for their neck say no I'm
tagging you oh that's what's happening
Oh something I'm gonna go you stand down
I am I am buying low while everyone's
selling in box safeties I'm bi and low
and I'm taking John Abram as my favorite
player in the draft it's official
it's official it's official like a rough
and a whistle damn we started this with
a freestyle and with a lot appreciate
you man good luck with everything for
real